NHS England has told Hospital trusts
that they must only remove gas and air
from maternity Wards as a last resort
several hospitals have temporarily
suspended the use of gas and air
following concerns that midwives and
staff are being exposed to excess levels
of nitrous oxide or joining me now is
the Midwife and author Leia Hazard good
morning to you Leia um can you explain
to us why these dangerous levels would
be happening in some hospitals and and
not in others
well I think it really comes down to
proper ventilation in certain units
labor ward in the UK today gas and air
is used regularly sometimes continuously
throughout the day and night and if
there is an adequate ventilation within
that rumor within that unit then levels
of this gas can accumulate within the
room and we know now that the levels in
some of these units where the gas has
been withdrawn were very very high and
so as to potentially cause danger to the
staff working there yeah I was just
going to ask how how long is this
problem of excess exposure been known
about and are there symptoms
well we don't really know to be honest
because uh I don't think uh to my
knowledge hospitals have really been
monitoring these levels consistently and
it's a shame because you know midwives
have already put up with a lot of
Airborne exposure of covid during the
pandemic we've already been trying to
raise our voices about adequate
ventilation and safe working
environments so uh unfortunately perhaps
not surprisingly
um you know these levels of antonox have
now caused concern whereas maybe this is
an issue that could have been addressed
if um levels had been monitored more
regularly
well that's that's very interesting I
mean you can understand why it would
create a panic anxiety amongst um
pregnant women
um what are the pain relief options if
if gas and air is not available
so for women who are
um you know 30 weeks plus pregnant what
sort of questions should they be asking
of their hospital so that they're not
um they're not negatively surprised or
caught on the back foot
I think the advice really is just to
keep in touch with your local hospital
where you plan to deliver if indeed you
do plan to deliver in hospital at all
and and just try and clarify which
measures if any they're taking to
monitor uh gas and air levels I know
some hospitals have reported that
they're using machines to kind of break
down these harmful levels of the gas in
the environment some units are actually
working on their ventilation as well but
I think the situation is changing day to
day so best advice is just to stay in
touch with the hospital
okay uh something else for pregnant
women to be worried about Leia has a
good to get your perspective on scan
news thank you